Today.
We welcome to the program Democratic Congresswoman
Barbara Lee, representing California's 12th
Congressional District, also a candidate for
the Senate seat currently held by Senator
Dianne Feinstein.
Congresswoman, really a pleasure having you
on.
I appreciate your time.
Nice being with you, Dave.
So, I mean, just to start with some of the
things that are that are going on right now,
yet again, we find ourselves in this position
of talking about the debt ceiling and are
we going to default and who's posturing politically
and for what different reasons.
Just as someone who's been through a number
of cycles of this.
Is this even remotely interesting at this
point or is it just a feeling of exhaustion
that this has to happen time and time again?
No, it's not a feeling of exhaustion.
I feel like that the Republicans, especially
the Republicans, have politicized this to
the point where it's confusing oftentimes
to the public when you incur debts.
And remember, a large portion of these debts
were incurred under Donald Trump with his
tax giveaways to corporations and the mega-rich.
When you incur your debt, you're obligated
to pay it.
And when you buy a car, you pay your car note.
If you default on your car note, they repossessed
the car.
And then if you go to get another car, the
interest rates will go up if in fact you can
purchase another car.
And so why they're politicizing this is primarily
to speak to their base and to the MAGA Republicans
who want to basically take away and cut Social
Security, cut veterans health, cut Medicare,
all of the cuts that they want to take place
around using people's lives really as hostage
for the debt ceiling.
And that's unacceptable.
We must pay our bills.
Then we talk about how we negotiate around
the budget.
I'm a member of the Budget Committee and the
Appropriations Committee, and that's the process
that should be used at this point.
Do you operate in Congress with the belief
that something like the debt ceiling debate,
which feels so distant to the lives of so
many Americans who just they go to work, they
might bring kids to school, their living,
their lives?
Do you operate with the belief or assumption
that something like the debt ceiling debate
can be used both positively and negatively
electorally, or that it's the type of thing
that just turns people off?
Well, I think people need to understand the
dynamics when you talk about debt ceiling.
We have to break it down.
And I looked at Kevin McCarthy, the speaker,
the speaker's district.
I mean, thousands of people will lose jobs.
The House, the people in his district will
lose their veterans benefit thousands of people.
Their retirement savings will be cut by at
least $20,000.
So thousands of people in his district alone
are going to be impacted.
When you look at child care, when you look
at early childhood education, when you look
at college education, young people need to
have college this debt free.
It's going to cost a heck of a lot more for
young people to go to college if we defaulted
on the debt.
So this has real impact on people's lives,
and that's why we're fighting so hard as Democrats.
To get these Republicans to understand we
must pay our debts.
We didn't have this issue under Donald Trump.
I mean, I think we raise the debt ceiling,
what, three times?
And that, you know, the Republicans were fighting.
And so this is a political issue.
They're trying to cater to the base, to Marjorie
Taylor GREENE And they really don't care about
who's lives that they're hurting.
But believe you me, Republican lives in Republican
districts and red states and blue states.
People are going to be hurt in a big way if,
in fact, we don't do this.
Congresswoman, with the benefit of hindsight,
we're now able to have quite, quite a precise
conversation about something like Afghanistan.
If we go back to the moments decades ago when
you were the only member of Congress to vote
against the authorization of military force
in Afghanistan after 911.
And we now go to Joe Biden carrying out some
version of the plan Donald Trump wanted to
carry out to get us out of Afghanistan, which
while not perfect, I believe, was absolutely
the right decision.
What can we now say in sum total about that
now that we have this these two decades going
back to your vote against that authorization
all the way through to the exit, although
some contractors remain?
What's the what's the retrospective on Afghanistan?
Well, first of all, yes, I voted against the
authorization because it came three days after
the horrific attack on our country.
First of all, thousands of people were died.
Still, thousands of people are dealing with
the health impacts of what took place.
And it was a 60 word authorization.
Three days after this horrific attack that
authorized not only President Bush, but any
subsequent president to go to war without
coming back to Congress.
That's unconstitutional.
I mean, we debate and authorize or not the
use of force for specific actions, not giving
the executive branch Congress is, which is
the people's voice, the authority.
And there's no way I could vote for that.
That was overly broad.
And it was it set the stage for perpetual
wars.
Fast forward to today.
We have used this administration, all administrations
since the Bush administration has used this,
and I think 19 or 20 countries non-related
to nine, 1141 times even.
And the Congressional Research Study provided
a declassified report.
It's been used for domestic surveillance in
our own country.
And so this was overly broad.
As I said, it was all we needed to debate
and come up with an appropriate response.
I'm not looking at the world through rose
colored glasses.
I mean, I know we have to have some form of
a response, but you have to have a rational
response that's appropriate that three days
after, while people are mourning, grieving
and angry.
And so now I'm trying to repeal this authorization,
and I've got bipartisan support to do that.
What the problem and the sticking point is
there are some who want to repeal and replace.
But what do you replace it with?
The president has to come to Congress to have
an authorization to replace whatever you need
the authorization to use force for.
So my repeal authorization stays in place
for eight months.
If the president determines he or she needs
an authorization to go to war, come back to
Congress, will debate it and provide it or
not.
What's your view on the withdrawal from Afghanistan,
which, you know, it wasn't perfect, but I
believe it was the right decision.
There was there were a number of criticisms
made of Joe Biden's withdrawal.
But when the former president, Donald Trump,
was initially asked what he would have done
differently, he wasn't really able to articulate
anything that he would have done differently.
So it seems that maybe there would have been
some chaos no matter when it happened.
What's your sense of it?
Well, my sense of it is that it had to be
done.
And yes, it was chaotic.
It wasn't planned.
But remember, this was set up by Donald Trump.
Yes.
He made and so President Biden did the right
thing.
It could have been done in a more organized
fashion where we could have I think then the
could have really provided a better safe passage
for those especially who protected U.S. troops
and who supported the U.S. in in Afghanistan,
the ousted population.
But he had to do this because most military
officials will tell you we'd be there 20 more
years and then 20 more years.
There was no military solution in Afghanistan.
And so why would we stay there another 20
years?
Our young men and women served bravely.
We lost a lot of troops.
A lot of our young men and women have health
impacts that will be with them for the rest
of their lives.
We have to make sure that they have the type
of medical care, employment and support that
they need, which of course the Republicans
are reticent to give them to support.
So, yes, President Biden did the right thing.
No, it was done well.
No, it was not done in an orderly way.
But the historical context has to be looked
at.
And what Donald Trump promised and how President
Biden had to execute right away, and that
was what took place.
Congresswoman, I want to talk a little bit
about the Senate race that you're involved
in right now.
This is a very interesting race.
We we've interviewed Adam Schiff, your colleague
and opponent in that race we hope to speak
to.
Katie Porter, also your colleague, an opponent
in that race.
You know, I get so many emails about that
race.
And one of the big concerns that people have
is that there are three congressional seats
here that are going to be vacated, which hopefully
would be filled by Democrats, all four one
Senate seat, which also, if Dianne Feinstein
were to resign, at least in the short term,
Gavin Newsom would get to appoint someone.
Gavin Newsom has said if he had that opportunity,
he would appoint a black woman.
Adam Schiff, Very nice guy, not a black woman.
Katie Porter, same thing.
So talk to me about the dynamics of this race.
Are there discussions within the halls of
Congress about the fact that these.
Three California House seats will be up for
grabs.
Talk us through it a little bit.
Well, I'm very focused on my race.
First of all, I have a very strong Democratic
district.
So I'm confident that we will elect a Democrat
in the 12th congressional District.
And yes, I'm running.
I was one of those that the governor had considered
once, once Vice President Kamala Harris resigned.
And, of course, the governor appointed, who
was a good friend and doing a great job, Senator
Alex Padilla.
But the governor did say if he had an appointing
authority, that he would appoint an African
American woman.
But let me tell you, I am running.
And going back to when he said that there
were two African-American women at the top
of his list.
One was at least we heard that was Mayor Karen
Bass and myself.
But I decided when after I talked to Senator
Feinstein in December, that she was going
to make her announcement very soon whether
she was going to run or not run.
And I waited.
And so she made her announcement that she
was not going to run.
That was in February.
Of course, my opponents were running already.
Yes.
But I waited.
I filed the next day after she announced she
was not running.
And I'm running.
And I think that my experience, my background,
my lived experiences, as well as my experiences
as a negotiator and as a progressive black
woman and as someone who fights not only for
marginalized communities, but for everyone,
for the middle class, for working families,
for people to have the quality of life that
they deserve, an economy that works for all
people who have not been seen.
You know, here in California, we have 20,
20% of our population is one paycheck away
from poverty.
No one in the Senate is fighting for the poor
and low income people and working families.
You don't hear that debate.
You don't hear the debate around climate change.
That and addressing climate the climate crisis
with environmental justice as part of that
in terms of what we do to mitigate the harm
of low income communities.
I am running in this race on a platform to
talk about inequality in housing and in my
shared experiences.
I had an abortion when I was 15 years old.
I co-chair the pro-choice caucus.
I fought to end the Hyde Amendment.
I had I talked about what happened during
my abortion.
Not only did I do that well, I did that because
finally with the Texas decision, I felt like
the public should know that there are members
of Congress who have these shared experiences.
And I am fighting now to make sure that we
codify abortion care into our law.
And so I have many, many experiences as a
small business owner or former small business
owner as a person start a community mental
health center.
My background is mental health and my MSW
in psychiatric social work and no one else.
A big issue here in California throughout
the country.
And so I think my experience is my ability
to negotiate my standing strong, sometimes
having to take on my party when I think they're
wrong.
And I have courage enough to do that because
this is who I am.
And of course, there are gaps in the Senate.
There are no black women in the Senate.
That perspective, the experience.
Representation matters, David.
Representation matters.
It seems there are basically three storylines
that are playing the largest role in what
are still the relatively early days of this
campaign.
One storyline is identity as you talk about.
A third storyline is who is the true or most
progressive.
And the third storyline is experience versus
age and sort of like what the voters are looking
for.
It seems as though this could get a little
bit awkward in the sense that I know you get
along well with your colleagues from California.
Do you have some conversation where everybody
says, hey, let's keep this clean?
Or It strikes me as the type of thing that
could become awkward?
Well, I don't think it's going to be all of
it.
I mean, it's a campaign, right?
Yes.
But believe you me, I know for a fact myself,
people don't like campaigns where you're hitting
below the belt.
And I was always and I was mentored by Congressman
Ron Dellums.
I worked for Ron for 11 years.
He was the first black chair of the Armed
Services Committee.
And Ron always told me and everyone on his
staff, you debate the policy, you bring great
experiences, you debate what your your historical
context and how you're going to use that for
the future to make lives better.
You don't hit below the belt.
You don't go personal.
You don't.
So, no, I don't do that.
I mean, I'm going to defend myself.
Yes.
If their lives told about me, I mean, come
on.
But I don't think it's an awkward campaign.
It's a this is a democracy.
People put out their record, who they are,
what they stand for, what they've done and
what they're going to do in the future.
And then people vote based on who they think
will best represent them.
Well, I'll tell you, a campaign based on policy
sound.
So refreshing given the context in which the
Republican Party has abandoned, even pretending
to talk about policy.
So that, I think, would be welcomed by many,
many voters.
We wish you the best in the campaign.
We've been speaking with Congresswoman Barbara
Lee, representing California's 12th Congressional
District.
I really appreciate your time and insights
today.
Thank you, David.
Nice being with you